well did you have it in your mind for a
little bit like oh you know I'd like to
do this and then you kind of wrestled
with it and then you said no I'm making
this no okay well I'm not suppose those
okay so after the economic downturn I
was very curious particularly about the
how Americans were feeling about the
country in the as i said the pursuit of
the American dream so that's pretty much
it was after that downtown that I
decided like lets you know I want to go
speak to the people of America and it
was all done on a bit of a whim really
because it sort of whimsical notions
yeah I drive across America not only did
he people and that's going to be easy
isn't it and in hindsight that kind of
was the easiest bit it's the actually
putting the film together after us which
is the really challenging bit the drive
across America at which we did over a
period of a month was that was easy but
that was enjoyable pleasant road trip
across america hey you know that's the
fun and so I had this in a whimsical
notion this would be a great idea I just
moved back into I've recently moved back
into a neighborhood in Brooklyn I hadn't
lived in for a long time and I've got to
know this Australian guy that ran this
cafe called smooching in fort greene in
brooklyn and and i just saw getting to
know this guy in for about a month and I
said I'm think about driving across
America and interview people he well
I'll come with you mate don't know you
very well but I don't know we've been
hanging out and he was kind of feeling
the same been in America the same amount
of time as i had so i thought well you
know i mean it once and they're so um it
was literally about two weeks later we
were on the road and doing it so it was
a very short period of time between the
inception idea inception some Aussie
guys said I'll come with you and being
on the road with an old camera man
friend of mine the sound friend of mine
in this stuffed in this van rolls of
film and seeing with the road tuchus you
know so yeah that was that and the
romance of it never wore off within that
month the bromance still continues no
we're the best of mates we actually made
it through this the whole experience not
just a trip itself but the making of the
film itself which as I said that's the
really challenging bit no one we're very
very very good friends and yeah it's
been great it's been a great experience
but one of those things where you think
oh yeah why not and you
me like wow god I did that you know
you